foreign
experience with therapy was about 20
years ago and it involved a four-year
sexual relationship with my therapist
you've had a really rough go of it huh
yeah
can I just tell you I'm sorry
[Music]
when I called you up this morning told
me about the new love you found
I said I'm happy for you hey welcome to
Dr John deloney's show we're so glad
that you're with us
Little Chicago in Nashville sung by
Texan not very well that's what we're
doing today on the greatest mental
health and parenting podcast in the
history of the world and marriage and
whatever else is going on in your life
so glad that you've given us the most
precious resource you have in your
entire life and that is your time thank
you so so much for giving us a buzz um
if you want to be on the show call us at
1-844-693-3291
1-844-693-3291 leave a message and Kelly
and or Jenna we'll call you back if they
call you back together
I mean you've won something have y'all
ever called somebody back together
um maybe when I was training Jenna but
that's it she does all the calls now
training Jenna that was awesome that was
a Lo-Fi Flex I like that
that was incredible
oh
A Day in the Life with Kelly all right
let's go to Nancy in Birmingham what's
up Nancy
hi Dr John thanks so much for taking my
call of course what's happening
um
I guess I'll just start writing yeah
jump in and then and then I'll uh I'll
steer us where we need to go
okay
I need to go back to therapy okay but I
am absolutely petrified
because my first experience with therapy
was about 20 years ago and it involved a
four-year sexual relationship with my
therapist okay
um why does that petrify you in the
future
I've been very very careful
to have a history of childhood sexual
abuse okay
and
just I'm just very very careful okay and
um
my my bigger issue I also don't trust
women so that makes it even harder why
don't you trust women
um
I have four older sisters the oldest one
is eleven I mean the one closest to me
so 11 years older than me and I was the
surprise
uh my
mother and father were greatest
Generation parents and
um we're busy doing their own thing and
I kind of was ignored and left my own
devices and no one paid much attention
to the fact that
I was it was clearly something wrong
you're struggling how old are you now
um I'm 55. 55. what what takes you back
to counseling nowadays
um
my son
was in an accident a head-on collision
uh his freshman year of college
and was a Glasgow three severe brain
injury coming in and
um
I have been his primary caregiver
um
girl for the last seven eight years
we just finished our 11th brain surgery
and I've hit burnout I I can't even put
my foot on the floor uh and I'm also
going back to what I know are negative
coping skills
disassociating cutting
um
just
things I had had really managed to quit
okay
you've had a really rough go of it huh
yeah
can I just tell you I'm sorry
um
I know you know this but it's gonna say
it out loud that shouldn't have happened
to you when you were a kid
nobody should have abused you nobody
should have
um
taking advantage of your body
your Mom and Dad should have seen that
they had a hurting little girl your
sister should have seen they had a hurt
and little sister and somebody should
have stepped in on behalf that little
girl
mentioned that abuser was my
brother-in-law okay oh man makes it even
worse right
yeah
I'm sorry
um
I'm also sorry that you went and sat
down with somebody who was a trained
professional
and you said here's how I'm hurting
and they took advantage of you
for four years
and for people listening to this yes it
takes two to tango yes takes two to have
sex with each other and all that
um
but it's the height of unethical
professional practice for a counselor to
engage in any sort of sexual
relationship with their clients period
because people come in and there's a
very emotional intimacy that happens in
a counseling setting there's a very
intimate setting
and
man you can take advantage of somebody
and that's what was done to you Nancy
and so on on behalf of counselors
everywhere I'm sorry that somebody took
advantage of you and treated you that
way they shouldn't have done that
thanks
and that brings us to right this second
okay
oh let me say this I'm also sorry man my
best friend on the planet my oldest best
friend is
um
a traumatic brain Survivor
um still paraplegic is never going to be
able to get up and run around and be
goofy like we used to be and
um struggles just to do basic life
things and
his mom is a saint and someone who I
love deeply his brother is one of my
oldest um closest friends on the planet
and
um I spoke at his dad's funeral very
close to me and I also know what kind of
trauma that ricochets through an entire
family so I'm sorry about your little
boy
okay
you're 55 which means you're a little
more than halfway done
right
statistically speaking
the question you have to ask yourself is
is this going to be Nancy's story
or
are you interested in changing
everything
not undoing what has happened the abuse
will always be there it happened that
the therapist that took advantage of you
will always be there your son's gonna
need care
but I'm talking about looking forward
and writing something new and building
something that hasn't existed before
it sounds like in a pretty dysfunctional
family system
that you can take the back half of your
life
and sleep for the first time in a long
time and laugh for the first time in a
long time and not only put your feet on
the floor but
go move around and hike and go for walks
and get child care and get the job but
you you see what I'm saying I'm talking
about building a whole new life are you
interested in that
yes okay
because what what it's going to take to
do that is you choosing to do the work
and not carry that stuff from the past
anymore the things that were done to you
we have to set the bricks down and start
doing things to our lives moving forward
and that's really heavy lifting are you
in for that because you've been
surviving for
45 years right
I mean
[Music]
try going back to therapy uh once uh
with the female and I could just feel I
mean one I might have changed shares
with me so I could sit closest to the
door okay
um and when I told her what had happened
with the other therapist her first
question was are you sure you didn't
misconstrue what was going on
and I cut up and walked there good for
you
good for you
see you got some strength in there don't
you
yeah yeah you do yeah I mean I quit my
job and I was
just top producer for the largest
company in our industry yeah no you're
you're an old tough gangster Nancy
and what you've been doing is using that
strength and that energy to survive
and to defend yourself from threats that
were there in the past that are no
longer pressing on you
but they're still pressing on you you
get you see what I'm saying
yeah and if you take that energy and
stop fighting old demons
they don't have any gas left in them
and use that energy to start building
something now you're talking about total
life transformation
and by the way
I saw my mom do it in her 50s and 60s
and now she's into her 70s
she just called yesterday and said she's
going to uh spin next summer as a
professor at Oxford and like she's just
living this crazy second half of her
life
and you can too
if you're all in
yeah but I gotta figure out how to make
that first
you do
no hold on back up there's no figuring
out
one of the things that's important to
know about our feelings is that they are
alarms or signals they're important and
they lie to us because our feelings have
one job and that's to Keep Us Alive
and so there's no figuring out how to
take the next step you just take the
next step so what does that mean as soon
as we get off this phone call
you call local counselor in your area
and there's a bunch of good ones in
Birmingham
and you don't lose sleep over a female
counselor call a male counselor
and tell them
20 years ago I went and saw a male
counselor and they
um took advantage of me sexually
that cannot happen again
and if they're a good counselor they'll
say thank you so much for sharing that
I'm grateful for you that will not
happen here in my office this is a safe
place
and then you're gonna have to make a
choice because your body's gonna start
sending the alarms off we're getting
close we're getting close and you're
gonna have to say no I'm gonna sit
through this one I'm gonna push through
the other side of this healing are you
into that
yeah I just oh so now I'm really hyped
to it exactly exactly here's a way to
diffuse the hyper vigilance call it out
thank you
even if you have to write down on a
piece of paper
I was sexually abused by a therapist I'm
very hyper Vigilant I've got sexual
abuse in my past I got a kid with a
traumatic brain injury that I'm a
primary caretaker for and I'm 55 and I'm
freaking exhausted and I want to live a
life of Joy with the time I got left
write that down
and take that on a piece of paper and
read it to the therapist that would be a
gift to any therapist
it'd be a gift because you're I'm taking
the air out of the hyper vigilance hyper
vigilance works in the shadows right it
lurks behind the facts and behind the
data and behind our lives and just keeps
us revved up for a fight that's probably
never going to come
right so I'm just going to turn all the
lights on I'm gonna I'm gonna turn the
lights on yep I'm super hyper Vigilant
right now
it kind of takes the it's it's like if a
bunch of Navy SEALs were coming into
your house and you flipped all the
lights and you're like I see all the
seals I'm not fighting you and you can
just arrest me in fact I handcuffed
myself
all right it's kind of like uh okay
right so am I gonna take all the hyper
vigilance away I'm just gonna make the
move I'm gonna go for it
so there's no figuring out the next step
it's just making the call and going
and then for you it's going to be
important is to go the second time and
to go the third time and it Go the
fourth time
hear me very clearly Nancy there is no
path forward that's going to be
comfortable
because your body's gonna fight you
every step of the way as you head on
into this New Path because it wants to
keep you safe
and right now what used to keep you safe
is now keeping you under water and your
body is saying we're out we're checking
out
so these feelings this hyper vigilance
this alertness that's been running the
show for so long
has pushed your body to a Breaking Point
and it's time for the thinking part of
your brain the rational part the fact
part the wait a minute I'm freaking
Nancy and I'm a baller I am getting back
in the driver's seat thank you for
driving philosoph 45 years feelings and
thoughts I'm grateful for you in hyper
vigilance you kept me alive good call
now I'm going to have some joy in my
life and I'm going to heal I'm gonna
quit carrying around this stuff from 20
years ago and 30 years ago and 40 years
ago
I'm gonna do something different
expect discomfort it's expect it
kind of like opening the oven and
sticking your hand in it's warm it's hot
and you got to be very careful but you
pull out a plate of cookies man so good
you gotta deal with the heat to get
those out already got to put your hand
in that freezing cold freezer to get the
ice cream out
just part of it it's good stuff
hang on the line I'm going to send you a
copy of own your pass change your future
my latest book I want you to read it
cover to cover and I want you to take it
with you to therapy take it with you to
your counselor and say hey I've read
this book and I want to take ownership
of some of these things I'm going to
start slowly shifting my thoughts and
actions and let's go make this thing
happen
I can't tell you how proud of you I am
Nancy
so proud of you 55 enough is enough
if you're listening you can be 65 you
can be 25 you can be 36 you can be any
age
the days enough's enough's enough is the
day that everything can be different
Nancy keep us and keep us keep us
notified let us know how this thing's
going can't wait to hear how your story
unfolds we'll be right back
hey deloney here and I've got a word
from our sponsor from betterhelp I've
been on the giving and receiving end of
therapy for years when I was spinning
out like a decade ago with wild anxiety
I had a moment that light bulb moment
that I knew I had to do something
different I knew I had to change
something probably a lot of some things
right but I found myself without the
tools for taking the next step
and when you're facing problems or
challenges in life it's way too easy to
get stuck in that anxious spiral of Doom
I've been there but when you learn how
to stop that cycle and start taking
ownership of your life that's when
you're free
and that's what therapy can help you do
it gives you the tools you need to do
the problem solving in your own life and
that's why I love better help better
help is online therapy that offers video
phone and even live chat sessions with
your therapist it's more affordable than
in-person therapy plus you can be
matched with a therapist in under 48
hours if you're ready to get the tools
that you need to deal with the
curveballs life's thrown at you therapy
can help visit betterhelp.com deloney to
get 10 off your first month that's
betterhelp.com deloney
all right all right let's uh let's go to
Steven in Atlanta dude I just all right
all right all right in it
shout out makana hey way to go man all
right let's go Steven in Atlanta what's
up Steven
hey Dr John how are you today I'm good
brother what's up man
all right so I'll just start with saying
um this year's been a long year for me
uh just I've had a long time with this
burnout I would I guess I would say
uh dealing with my job have another baby
on the way and um you know I just feel
exhausted yeah
well um how can I help man
I guess uh you know I've
had three panic attacks in the past
several months and yeah and lead with
that next time dude
sorry about that yeah I got a busy job
and a baby and I'm dying hey
and uh yeah so yeah I definitely had
some experience where I felt like that I
was gonna die a couple of times
um yeah and different times I just felt
lightheaded and uh
really don't know where to go from there
cool
so we're going to start at the top and
I'm going to peel this thing apart okay
is that cool
sure
um tell me to stop asking questions if
you ever say like I'm just don't answer
anymore
um and know this this exploration will
help a lot of people okay it's pretty
it's a brave call you made
um so a panic attack is your body
it's really overriding the system okay
it's it's telling you hey you clearly
aren't hearing me
so uh I'm sounding every alarm I have
all of them at the same time
okay it's a just an over regulation it's
a dysregulation of the regulatory system
right so let's back out
um tell me about your job what do you do
for a living
uh I work in the automotive industry
okay service advisor as a what advisor
service advisor okay what about that job
is burning you out
um really handling about 20 to 30
customers a day okay
and working about 12 hours a day okay
why do you do that job man
uh the money's good how much is good
what kind of money do you make
uh I would say upwards of 150 000 okay
150 Grand a year okay great salary
as far as helping customers I loved
dealing with that aspect
it's just the hours are daunting you
just told me that the worst part of the
job was 30 or 40 customers a day or 20
30 customers a day and it's the best
part
um helping the customers is the best
part uh but yeah I guess you're right
about that
um 20 to 30 customers can be
overwhelming okay for me
um tell me about these hours why do you
work these crazy hours is that just what
the job demands that's what the job
demands right
do you have any other kids wife married
anything like that
uh wife and I have a two-year-old son
okay tell me about your home life tell
me about your wife
oh my wife is wonderful
um our marriage uh couldn't ask for more
she's a wonderful support
um my son I love him to death I try to
go home and spend time as much as
possible with them okay
for him or with him
uh with him
okay
so have you created a life for yourself
this is a side question
um
what do you owe
as far as from a financial standpoint
yep
um I'm debt free except for my house
okay so what do you own your mortgage
uh I have 165 000 left on my mortgage
to quit your job right now quit it
yeah
okay what I just did after that
what I just would I sometimes I'll just
say hey just break up with her
just quit your job
and I want to know what people's gut is
and your response I'm judging you by one
syllable but it you're like yeah
what is right like you make a great
salary
but financially speaking you're better
off than 99.9 of people in the in in on
planet Earth
all right
yo 165 Grand you're gonna have no house
payment how old are you
34. how old
34. okay 34. so by 36 you'll be you'll
have no house payment
you don't owe anybody anything
and for 150 Grand you're choosing to
live a life of misery and disruption
why is that
I guess because I've been doing it for
almost 10 years and I
really haven't really sought out
anything else
when the story on you is written like on
the Epitaph would you love it to say
helped a lot of people with their
Automotive issues
no
bad thing I mean that's like man I fixed
a lot of cars I help people get to work
and get to the hospital that's not a bad
thing I'm just asking is that what you
want on on
etched into stone next to your name
no I mean absolutely not what do you
want to do
um
I guess really just that I was an
individual that laid down
my life or others and laid down my heart
for others to help others
um get the point a from point A to point
B okay and so do you see that your work
is in service to that mission
because I do I get it
right
I mean I I can see that you know as far
as
helping people with their cars and
everything but I I don't know I'm just I
guess I'm looking for more in life than
just that yeah there you go
um tell me about your buddies who do you
hang out with once a week just to grab a
beer with the nachos with who's your
gang
really I have no one
um because I've wrapped my life and
family and work okay
um
I don't know if you can do this but tell
me about the crummiest boss you have
uh well I mean currently I actually do
not have any crummy bosses everybody's
good how many bosses in the past
everybody's good I mean I have a great
relationship with all my bosses okay
so if I were to ask you man what's your
body trying to get your attention like
what's it trying to tell you what would
what would your answer to that be
rest
tell me more
um just going going and not giving time
for myself
okay
is that going going going your body's
version of laying down its life for
everybody else
okay
some reason we got in our heads that if
it doesn't hurt it's not a good workout
and if it doesn't hurt then it's not a
good if we're not hurting then we're not
sacrificing and crushing ourselves on
behalf of our wives or our kids then
we're not putting it all in
or if we're dying at the altar of our
job or paycheck that somehow we're if
we're not dying at the altar of our
paycheck we're somehow screwed something
up and I think that's stupid
my friend Sal over the Mind pump guys
was the first guy I'd ever heard say
that a lot of people work out until
they're sore
because they hate their bodies
and there's some sort of underlying idea
that I need to punish myself through
this workout
to to to to make sure my body gets to
message that the way it looks is
unacceptable and he he was like dude
that's a recipe for Burnout
and so some some story that you're
operating under says that
you have to do all of these things
and your body's trying to get your
attention say hey hey we can't do all
these things we cannot work 12 hours a
day six days a week we cannot be fully
present with our kids we cannot have the
greatest marriage ever we cannot
um we're out I'm out
is that fair oh and then you throw
another kid on there and then your
body's like oh good thanks thanks Steven
that's what we need that's what we
needed another human
yeah no I I totally agree with what
you're saying who told you that uh 12
hours a day six days a week was was the
way the way to fulfill your duty
uh no one really told me that somebody
modeled that somebody modeled that for
you
um I guess I just kind of become
accustomed to it uh well I mean
as far as when I first started my job
that was the norm of everybody that's in
this industry
um work work work and
no rest and then um you know
once rest kind of comes and you pick up
and work again have you seen some of the
dudes that are 45 and 55 in your
industry
I have they look a hundred
they do
their bodies are a hundred
is that the life you want for yourself
not really no Okay so
here's what I'm trying to give you
choice
often I talk to folks in your situation
and they owe a hundred thousand dollars
in student loans and they have two car
payments and they owe 500 000 on their
mortgage and so this conversation is
very different because I tell them
you're gonna have two or three years
more of this
um so that you can dig out of the hole
that you dug for yourself
and then you can fill in the blank you
don't have that issue
you have a wide array of choices
all burnout is is when your body says
hey you haven't been listening to us so
clearly you're not you don't know what
you're doing we're taking over
it's like when you're in driver's ed and
there's a another break
on the on the instructor's side of the
car too
that he can slam on that break if you
are missing it as a driving student
that's what you're that's what a panic
attack is it's your body just shutting
the thing down because you clearly
aren't getting the message and so what I
would love you to do is to start to get
the message
it starts with here's like you're create
you're talking about an anxious life
right that's what you're talking about
you have a life that's just buzzing all
the time is that correct right that's
correct how much coffee do you drink
uh one cup in the morning really
yeah good for you man
gosh I think I had seven this morning
that's impressive how do you go to sleep
at night
I do yeah so there's something else
you're not telling me
I mean as far as how's your how's your I
know your wife's pregnant you have a
two-year-old how's your sex life how's
your intimacy life
um
there it is right there there it is what
maybe once every three weeks right now I
mean of course about once a week but
um just the way you said well
um
so whenever somebody says hey I have an
anxious life here's the life before me
okay
the three buckets I like to to look at
before anything else
is number one uh there's four buckets
actually number one is physiological
I'd recommend at this point if you've
had three panic attacks go see your
doctor okay
get your heart checked get your thyroid
checked get your testosterone checked
get some of these basic low-level things
checked just to make sure okay all right
the second thing is
if you if you open your eyes you know
six thousand years ago and you were on
the planes of Texas and your tribe had
left you you were probably going to die
wired into us at our more most core
function
is this idea that we have to be around
other people and I tell new dads and new
moms all the time the greatest gift you
can give your toddler
is to go have your own friends
to leave the house once a week and go
hang out with your friends
I took my 12 year old son I have a we
are incredible Stephen I got like a rock
and roll band that I'm jamming with
okay I brought my 12 year old over the
other day
he watched us for about 12 minutes until
he's about to fall asleep on the couch
and then I said you can go outside and
swim in this guy's pool
by the way get a guy in your band that
has a pool it's way it's super great
um but I wanted him to see his dad
having friends
and I wanted him to see my life does not
revolve around him
because he is not strong enough to be
the center of my solar system
and he'll try to be
okay so getting with your wife and
saying Hey I want you to start having
friends that you do life with and so
once a week so you hear me say y'all are
planning to be a part two nights out of
a week minimum
I want her to go start spending an
evening with some girlfriends and that
means you're gonna do dinner you're
gonna do bath time you're gonna do
bedtime
okay you're gonna get plugged in in that
way and you can put your phone down and
you're just gonna be there as annoying
as that is
oh it's gonna be the worst and but I'm
still gonna plug in that way
and
you're gonna get a couple of dudes
you're gonna start hanging out and
that's gonna be weird and awkward 35 is
the single it's the worst time to start
making friends and here you are okay
your brain will not rest until you've
got a gang
all right and I would also recommend
they not be work people either
gotcha okay
the the third bucket is this idea of
safety are you in a place that's not
safe and you told me no I don't have a
toxic work environment my marriage is
fantastic
um Family Life Is Good your debt to
income I mean you've got basically no
debt man you're almost paid your whole
house off you're not even 40 years old
yet which is just astounding it's
incredible then the third thing is
autonomy and this is the big another big
one where your body isn't in control of
what happens tomorrow
and it can often look up after being at
the same job for 10 years and you're
working 12 hours a day six days a week
and it begins to feel like this is the
rest of my life
and that's what your body begins to
revolt because it doesn't have a say in
what happens tomorrow
and so you have to start having the
conversation with yourself about what
does my work life look like in the next
two to three years
like do I need to go get credentialed do
I need to go to college do I need to get
something like what do I actually want
to do
in service to this greater Mission and
by the way like follow your passion I
think that's just stupid I'm just not a
passion guy
um we're passionate about the things
that we're good at and we're good at the
things that we practice and we practice
the things usually that we have to right
so
um I liked guitar I thought guys who
were playing guitar looked cool and they
seem to have dates a lot so then I
started playing it and I hated it
because it was hard and then I liked
being able to play one song and then 35
years later I'm passionate about guitars
you see what I'm saying it wasn't like
I'm passionate about this thing I have
this feeling about man
it doesn't it doesn't usually work in
reverse and so I care less about what
you're passionate about and more about
dude who are you what do you want to do
and then do you have any sort of
exercise practice at all
I'm trying to implement that into my
life right now no as Yoda says there's
no try just do it man
just do it just do it get a couple of
dumbbells from Academy and just take
them to your house and start there
you can get through the next six months
of your life with two dumbbells and
that's about it
Yeah okay or get on Craigslist and buy
just some Shenanigans I have a dope home
gym that is made up almost entirely of
Craigslist finds oh nice okay and it
took me like three or four or five years
to accumulate it all just keep doing it
it's fantastic man
but you have to build that in and I'm
not talking about a two and a half hour
Beefcake McGee workout go outside and do
30 minutes and lift some weights go
outside and go for a jog go outside and
walk around in nature okay
the last thing I'll tell you is this
um if you can incorporate all this
together
get your dumbbells and go outside in
your backyard and do your morning
workout in the Sun
even when it's cold
get some sunlight and get some nature
and get some exercise and get some
movement and get some coffee you see
what I'm saying we're talking about
slowly tweaking the edges of our life
it's gonna have a ripple effect all the
way through the middle of it
right got it
now I just told you a bunch of stuff
does that say like okay I'm in for that
or like man you're an idiot
no I'm actually absolutely into that
okay I'd love to keep up with you as
you're walking
um if you're like me I don't like
calling doctors I've been to my primary
care physician zero times in the last
five years so much so that I went and
got like special doctors because I just
don't want to go to a record doctor
please call and make a appointment with
with the primary care doctor
okay
have you done that yet
I actually have how'd that go
um everything checked out fine okay cool
the physical Spectrum good bucket bucket
done now before I let you go
one of the the like no no one uh let's
see lesson number one in counseling
class whenever I was teaching grad
school or I was in grad school
lesson number one your clients will lie
to you
they'll tell you most of the story are
part of a story so before I let you go
to put you on the spot completely
something in my guts tells me there's
something else
am I wrong
not that I can think of I mean I've
planned on being straightforward with
you throughout this whole thing so I
mean I I don't have anything that I can
think about that like you're not
cheating on your wife you don't have
like an addiction or you don't owe
somebody a bunch of money or something
I do not no sir
Stephen yes you know I'm just messing
with you no that's fantastic that's
awesome dude here's the thing you sound
like an incredible guy
you sound like an incredible guy
and there's people this is hard for us
to wrap our heads around
um
I think his name was Marlon Ramsey was
the the
race when I was I was a track athlete in
high school and kind of a wannabe poser
in college
and I remember
buying into coaches saying like man you
can do anything you can be so fast you
can do all these things you just got to
work hard to work hard and work hard
and so I thought my Excellence was a
function of my hard work which in many
ways it was but it was my excellence and
I think his name was Marlon Ramsey I
think he went on to run at Baylor and
then in the Olympics but I got
he ended up on in the same heat of a
race as me at the rice Invitational
relays there in Texas in Houston
and he beat me so bad
like he just annihilated me and I
remember realizing that I think I was a
freshman maybe a sophomore and I
remember realizing
I could never exercise and work hard and
be that fast that dude's just faster
than me and he's working as hard as me
so there's a gap right so that same
thing with jumping like Michael Jordan
or doing squats like Lane Norton like I
could do squats every day and follow a
great program I'm not going to set the
world record I'm just not
here's what I'm telling you that
we look around in the Instagram world
that we live in in the yeah crush it
kill it world
and there's some people
that are just Ford f-350s
they seem to be able to do 12-hour days
six days a week and go and go and go and
go
and we don't have any long-term data oh
and though that engine craps out right
but it just they we see them and we see
their success
and for many of us we have to look in
the mirror and say
I'm a I'm a Camry
it's a great car it's gonna last forever
but I can't do a job that is six 12-hour
days for 50 years and call it
I'm put here to do something different
my job is not to pull a building down my
job is not to carry heavy equipment my
job is to get people from A to B I'm
going to be the best A to B getter
person in the world
you see what I'm saying
right I do you may have put yourself in
a situation where this isn't the job for
me
or this isn't the life I want to live in
this particular season
and I've told us on the show before but
there came a moment when I was about
your age almost identical to your age
actually
when my wife and I took a 70 000
household income pay cut
and I quit working at a giant at a not a
giant but at a large University running
a big ship and I went to a bigger
University but working with a smaller
subset of students
um The Prestige was still enough so that
my ego could prop itself up but the pay
was less the responsibility was less and
then I spent a season working out I got
an engine replacement
and now I got an engine replacement I
got new wheels and new brakes and new
tires and I learned new things and I got
new skills and I got a little bit wiser
A Little Bit Stronger then all of a
sudden I was a way different vehicle
does that make sense
it does so just a season it was good I'm
glad I had it during the middle of it I
hated every second of it I thought it
was the worst I thought it was a failure
I thought I was a loser I wasn't and by
the way the money on the back end
it's a totally different proposition
right so that pay cut that we took was
one of the greatest Investments we've
ever made as a family
but I want you to start an exercise I'm
going to send you a couple things I'm
going to send you a copy of my book on
your pass change your future okay read
it with your wife
the second thing I'm going to send you
is
questions for humans the couple's
Edition I want you and your wife to
start spending some date time okay
so intimacy time it's not doesn't have
to be sex related that's just
communication we're talking again I'm
also going to send you my buddy Ken
Coleman's book from paycheck to purpose
and I want you to read that thing start
to finish and start asking yourself some
of the bigger questions man I've got 10
years of management experience of making
great money I know how to work hard
what kind of car do I want to be what
kind of engine do I put in this thing
over time is there something else I want
to do and you may Circle back and say
nope this is what I want to do I just
want to manage the time better I'm going
to start taking time off I'm going to
whatever
and take one of those older guys out to
lunch that you work with um one of the
dudes that's been there for 35 years and
he's 60.
take him back and say hey when you're 35
. give me some wisdom to your 35 year
old self
I did that once when I was working at a
print shop in college I was about two
years in and I was just bored of college
it was just boring and I worked at a I
was a delivery boy at a print shop and
there was these guys been working the
press for years the dude's name was
Merlin it's awesome guys the incredible
drummer
and we went out to lunch one day just
it was awesome man his hands are ink
stained he's just a great human long
hair we went out and um I said what
would you would what would you tell me
your 20 year old self and he looked at
me and said graduate college
and he said it was a conviction of I
love my life I do well in my life
but there's more than this
and man working at print shops those
guys were incredible Vance Merlin those
dudes were awesome but he looked at me
in the eye and said graduate college
go beyond this and so sit down with
somebody's a little bit ahead of you and
ask for some wisdom there okay
you're on the right path my brother
Stephen and I'm grateful that you called
and thanks for letting me unpack all
that with you know that was a little bit
of a longer unpacking but if you're
listening to this and you experience
panic attacks you experience anxiety
ask yourself some of the questions I
just asked Steven what's my intimacy
like who am I hanging out with let's get
a medical checkup
am I safe financially am I safe in a
toxic work environment what's my sex
life at all like what what is the world
I've created for myself that my body is
telling me we cannot make it here
anymore
[Music]
fixing your body is less important than
creating a new environment for yourself
to live in
and yes go outside and lift weights too
we'll be right back
hey folks Dr John deloney here look we
live in a culture that glorifies the
grind everything's about corrosion and
killing it and go go go go and we like
And subscribe and follow anyone with
tips on how to hack our way to doing
more and being more and we sacrifice
sleep at the altar of productivity and
my friends we are exhausted hustling is
well and good but burnout is real and
when you're running hard you must
remember to recharge your body with
sleep sleep is the Cornerstone to
physical and mental health and for me
getting great sleep starts with a great
mattress that's why I love dream Cloud
right now dream cloud is running an
awesome offer for our listeners 599
dollars in accessories plus an
additional 250 discount that's a total
of eight hundred and forty nine dollars
in accessories and savings you'll get
pillows a mattress protector and luxury
sheets it's time to ditch burnout
culture and start prioritizing your
sleep go to dreamcloudsleep.com deloni
or or dreamcloudsleep.com and enter
promo code deloni to get your new
mattress today and enjoy 849 dollars in
savings and accessories
all right we're back hey I got a couple
of emails I want to work through here
with you one is a follow-up email
someone who reached out recently and was
on the show and then circled back and
said here's how things are going and
then the other is a
an all-important life hack question from
Wendy so uh you want to stay tuned for
that all right so here is the email from
Mandy
and she called in Kelly what was this
call about she called in about her
respecting her immature husband right
and it just aired um it aired in August
I believe in August 12th so it's a
recent one yes okay
so here's what she writes this makes me
feel good
follow up with a smiley face I love me a
good smiley face emoji I like a good
smiley face emoji made out of
punctuation marks way to go
said thank you Dr John for the years of
Saved time and energy and counseling oh
boy we have a meeting her and her
husband have a meeting every Wednesday
at 7 that he sets up and reminds me now
we also talk about a relationship once a
week after finances he set up a
financial advisor meeting and we went
together
wow
he is like this is this is for many
people sexier than any sort of Barry
White music you could possibly play
he stopped drinking what
and he told me the other day that he is
actually happier
foreign
I can't thank you enough for being so
real and honest with me and helping me
set hard boundaries smiley face
Mandy you made my day thank you so so
much
um often these conversations go sideways
and setting up boundaries for the first
time your partner says oh yeah we'll
screw you I'm off to something else
and so setting up boundaries is always a
terrifying risk
often it goes sideways and often
this happens your partner doesn't want
to live like the life that they're
living either
they want somebody to stop the music and
say can we do another kind of dance what
are we doing
um they want somebody to say hey I don't
like this meal somebody to say hey my
needs are different your needs are
different you don't like me and I'm
frustrated that you don't like me
how can how can I help you like me right
and that's what Mandy did she sat down
and had some hard conversations about
their money about his immaturity about
his drinking just plopping on the couch
and it was hard and she did it and I'm
proud of you Mandy so let this be the
first step into some new adventures
Mandy it will get harder trust me it
will get harder and the things that he
was covering up with his drinking they
will surface at some point and the old
routines will start calling for you
and that's when the uh the work will get
real it'll get real hard
and
I trust you guys are gonna keep hanging
in there it's so fantastic good for you
and I've got this email here from Wendy
and when he writes a scary terrifying
question
how do I stop scrolling through Facebook
and YouTube all day
question mark
that's all this says that's the entirety
of the email
I'll read it again for those of you who
are driving
how do I stop I don't know why you were
driving they just sounded funny how do I
stop scrolling through Facebook and
YouTube all day
well Wendy you've come to the right
place I'm not very smart on a lot of
things but I got your back on this one
I'm going to teach you a hack
um I love hacks
hacks are so stupid there's no such
thing but I'm gonna I got one I got one
um
you consume Facebook and YouTube
um through these magical devices
they have screens on them they're either
smartphones uh tablets iPads TVs
um
anything
probably some glasses I don't know
you're probably gonna plant it into your
head but they're consumed on electronic
devices and I did not know this existed
it's fantastic but on all electronic
devices
hold your hold your hats ladies and
gentlemen
there's an off button
and you can just push the crap out of it
and the whole thing just goes and turns
off and then no more Facebook and no
more YouTube
it just stops it stops that's life hacks
uh 101 with Dr D here and here's the
here's the Here's the the the real truth
here
we scroll Facebook and YouTube because
we're freaking lonely
and we scroll Facebook and YouTube
because
um we don't like the the worlds we've
built for ourselves or we're bored or
we're spacing out or we're trying to
numb or we're trying to distract
and I am the worst
my crack is Instagram I'll just sit
there and scroll forever
how do you stop scrolling build a life
worth living
you want to know how to get off the
internet how to stop spending all your
days on social media build yourself a
life worth living
that makes going to a screen seem like
an absurd waste of your time because
your real life is being lived over here
the number of couples I talk to that sit
on the couch and just scroll Instagram
he's on espn.com and she's on Pinterest
and you know what they could be doing it
they could be doing it right there and
they're not they're just scrolling
they're just scrolling biologically
that's insane that's Matt what are you
doing
or people just stand in line surrounded
by a whole bunch of other people and
they just look at their phones you know
what you could be doing
hang with me here you could go hey
what's up how's it going
yesterday I was walking to the store and
this guy was buying like a 20 pack a 30
pack of beer and he dropped it and it
exploded
and it was incredible and his reaction
was he started dying laughing and then I
started laughing and then everybody
started laughing and then they came over
and helped him clean up his beer and he
was covered in it and I made some jokes
he made some jokes it was amazing and if
I had been scrolling on some sort of
stupid platform I would have missed all
of it
I would have candy crushed my way out of
a guy dropping a case of beer on himself
it was phenomenal and then he had the
greatest reaction ever because he's just
started dial laughing it made my heart
so big
build a life worth living
for most of us that means engaging in
relationships that are hard that means
asking ourselves is this the place I'm
gonna work for the rest of my freaking
life
it's asking ourselves did this t-shirt
really make me feel better about myself
or this new guitar or this new gun or
this new car or this bigger house or
this new person I'm texting even though
I'm married to somebody else is that
actually create no it's not
taking a mess and making it more chaotic
how do I stop scrolling through Facebook
and YouTube all day
build a life worth living
be a person other people want to be
around
invite people into your life
do something different we'll be right
back
hey deloney here one of the things I
love about my job is answering the tough
questions people have when they call
into the show your stories are
incredible in each person's situation is
unique and for years people from all
over the world have been asking if I do
private counseling or private coaching
sessions for them or for their spouse
and as much as I'd love to I can't
realistically do one-on-one coaching
sessions with every single person it's
just not possible but that's exactly why
I wrote my new book own your past change
your future within the pages of this
book is exactly what I would say if you
and I were sitting down together at a
table looking for the next right move
for you to make in your relationships or
to help you live a more whole and
peaceful life as you read through each
section of this book I will show you how
to look and own the roads from your past
and head to the New Roads of a well life
moving forward go to John deloney.com to
get your copy today that's own your past
change your future at John deloney.com
all right we're back I was just
um
this occurred to me the other day
how much energy I spent in my life
sitting in a room
with other grown men
watching a big screen
of other grown men playing a game
I watch other grown men play a game
against other grown men when I could be
outside actually enjoying my life and
playing that game
I go to movies and I watch other people
have great romance I take my wife to a
movie and watch other people
have romantic time together
congratulations everybody this is the
life we've built for ourselves
oh my gosh
so song of the day is
Kelly has a thing for Pet Shop Boys like
literally and and it happens to be her
favorite band too which is kind of cool
this is um I think all these old bands
are coming out with records because
they're been looking at their 401ks kind
of kind of they're like you know what
maybe we should get over ourselves and
make new records because there's a lot
of older bands hitting the tours but
anyway
Pet Shop Boys got a new record out is
that right
I guess I found it on when I I was
looking for songs about social media can
you get another tattoo it came out in
2019 so it's fairly new I heard you went
to the tattoo shop to get Pet Shop Boys
tattooed and they're like I can't I
won't do that
not true you have no reason to talk you
get tattoos all the time all right Pet
Shop Boys Kelly's 15th favorite favorite
band favorite this is the King James
version The Pet Shop Boys favorite band
the song's called on social media and it
goes like this when you care about the
issues of the day check your facts on
Wikipedia you can get into an argument
right away if you're on social media
awesome the world is changing everywhere
with a speed that couldn't be speedier
but you feel so ahead of the curve when
you're on social media you're part of
the conversation you're there in every
debate from football to religion to
Contemporary Art you're ready to
pontificate Pet Shop Boys you've got a
new fan right here while democracy is
losing its way and greed is getting
greedier consult yourself with a selfie
or two and post them on social media my
likes are in the thousands my tweets are
being retweeted my family picks their
holiday snaps with total love or greeted
it's so nice when people like you you're
feeling hashtag blessed when you're
on social media Pet Shop Boys shout out
that was dope
and you're also dope you America we'll
see you soon
[Music]